hey what's up guys mkbhd here remember
the google cr-48
now
let me fill you in basically the cr-48
was the first ever chromebook and it was
sort of a test pilot for google's chrome
os now you probably already know what
google chrome is in fact if you're like
me you're probably watching this video
in chrome right now but chrome os is a
little bit different because it's the
only thing that you turn on when you
turn on the computer so google chrome is
the entire operating system it's it's
just the browser so there's no windows
no mac os 10 no linux you just turn on
the computer and boom google chrome
turns on that's it now i think and you
can give a thumbs up on this video if
you agree i think chrome os is a little
bit ahead of its time it's a little bit
too far into the future and it's trying
to make its way here in the present and
that's why it's not being so successful
right now hear me out maybe you'll agree
basically everything that's awesome
already about google chrome as a browser
just turns into everything that's
awesome about the operating system so
the super fast startup times you can
open up the laptop and it'll resume like
nearly instantly it's very secure and
it's just really really fast everything
just works you even have device sync so
it'll sync with the chrome on your other
devices so things like that it just
makes it seem like a very complete
platform and why not use chrome i mean
chrome is a really good idea for that so
you gotta have apps because you can't
just live in the browser forever
sometimes you need to just get stuff
done with applications uh there is a
chrome app store it's called the chrome
web store so these are turning into
things that are way beyond just
glorified websites or shortcuts so
basically sometimes you get an app in
the chrome web store where you click on
the icon it just takes you to the
website for that app where they're
actually turning now into real apps like
applications that are running your
browser so you click on it and you'll be
get this new beautiful interface that
looks nothing like the web app and it's
really interesting to use so you can
check out the links in the description
below for stuff like chromebooks and the
chrome web store and i'll keep telling
you why chrome os is so awesome yeah i
said chromebooks because chrome os is
the operating system itself but it's
also being kind of unsuccessful right
now because chrome books aren't selling
very well i bet you didn't know you
could buy chromebooks in like your local
best buy have you even seen one on a
shelf i have but i look for them there
are samsung chromebooks out there there
are asus chromebooks out there and
there's a test pilot which was the cr-48
and right now there are very low spec
machines and this is why google drive
flies into the picture and really
completes the entire package it really
makes it
an ecosystem kind of almost see these
chromebooks don't need to cost very much
because they need to be affordable for
people who need a simple computer like
that and they also only have to run
google chrome so they make them you know
have an intel mobile processor maybe an
atom processor maybe one gigabyte of ram
a dedicated video card won't be
happening in the chromebooks and you
really just have a low spec and you'll
have maybe eight maybe 16 gigabytes of
internal storage on these chromebooks it
seems like enough when you're only using
google chrome but then you realize you
want to make it like an actual computer
so you're going to need you know store
your photos store your documents and
view you know listen to your music and
all that kind of stuff and you're gonna
need more than eight gigs google drive
comes into the picture and suddenly you
have 25 gigs of external storage that's
just on google's cloud servers you don't
have to worry about it it's really
really cheap and if you need more than
that you can pay for more it's a genius
system and it's very inexpensive and
it's just a great ecosystem with the
chromebooks so overall you're getting
chrome chrome os and tab sync across
multiple platforms you get the chrome
web store you get the chrome apps you
get all these different things that are
just kind of revolving around each other
and making a great package in a
chromebook and it's just not selling
well at all and that's why i think it's
ahead of its time people aren't really
ready to move fully to the cloud for
their laptop computer personally i think
an awesome machine would be this
something with sort of a macbook air
form factor running chrome os okay
having a massive battery and just having
maybe eight gigs of internal storage
having a massive amount of stuff in
google drive
and large battery uh ultra low voltage
processor and
have it say google on the back i don't
know i mean it would be pretty sick
chromebook make it maybe matte black or
something like that
and i would definitely like that as a
secondary machine now obviously you
can't replace your full desktop because
you know video editing apps and photo
editing photoshop and things like that
can't really be replaced in the cloud
completely yet i mean they're getting
there but right now i think chromebooks
are a definite awesome option for a
secondary machine and uh it's what i'm
using mine for right now either way i
just gotta thank lamar wilson from
wilson tech one because this video would
not be possible without him and also all
of you guys who have recently subscribed
uh who have found my channel thank you
welcome aboard and i hope you're
enjoying these videos either way thanks
for watching leave a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it and i just hit the microphone
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching guys
peace
you